Euuuu...
Voila c'est un début d'intro buggé *rires*
Je cherchais un truc a faire ben je vais rien faire finalement rien faire c'est quoi c'est faire quelque chose
C'est comme le vide il n'y a pas de vide
Le vide c'est forcément quelque chose bon
Sur cette intro philosophique de merde *rires*
On est aujourd'hui sur Hello Neighbor on avait fait une vidéo sur ce jeu il y a très longtemps il y a plusieurs mois je crois
On vient d’emménager ici on a un voisin en face qu'on suspecte d'être un peu fou voir même d'emprisonner des gens
Voir même de séquestrer des gens
C'est la même chose au final
Donc le jeu à grandement évolué à parement de ce que j'ai vue il y a pas mal de pieces qui sont difficle d'accès
Faut trouver comment y accéder pour au final accéder à la pièce final
Et ça fait beaucoup de fois le mot "final"dans cette intro
bref c'est parti !!!
De la glue !?
Sa peut peut-être servir à aaa..le le...à le gluer au sol finalement
Un réveil Ah ! c'est pour l'attirer je me souvient sa fait du bruit ok
Et on peut prendre la chaise aussi
Bon d'façon de base là j'ai rien donc autant prendre une chaise mon gars !
On pourra toujours lui envoyer dessus si il me casse les couilles
il va pas être la direct normalement non
Putain ! j'aime pas l'ambiance qu'il y a dans cette maison mec !
Il y a la pire ambiance d'Europe elle est là !
Est-ce qu'il y a pas des objets à trouver je suis sur il y a des objets à trouver
je me souvient quand il y avait le jeu il y avait par exemple une lampe à lumiere noir
pour lire un code caché sur les murs pour ouvrir des portes...fin bref c'est un délire
Donc là il y aura exactement la même chose
Oh ! Putain c'est moi ! j'ai cru qu'il était derrière moi et que j’avais vue via son ombre
La panique était total !
Oh ! Une lampe ! Oui ! OUI !
C'est ex-ac-te-ment ce dont on révait
Bon ici il y aura rien d'autre je pense qu'on à trouver le premier truc
Ok ici il y a une porte on va accédé à la porte "mec"
"What the fuck mec"(c'est quoi ce bordel)
*bruit de moteur*
ça sert à quoi ça ? je comprend pas !
Bon je sais pas ! Sa servira peut-être plus tard à quelque chose
Pare-contre j'peut pa...*Silence*Il y a eu un bruit et je peut-pas changer d'objet...Bon c'est pas grave
Voisin : Oh ! Squezzie : Oh bâtard ! OUAAAAAA !
Oh j'ai réussit a m'enfuir !?OH JE SUIS TROP CHAUD ! I AM SO HOT !
J'ai réussit a m'enfuir pour de vrai ? Ah ben non il s'arrête en fait d’accord il vient pas non plu te choper !
Bâtard va ! Tient !! Glue ! Glu...Mais sa sert à rien de mettre de la glue je suis con !
Par contre après mec j'arrive pas à changer d'objet...sa c'est chiant ça
Il y a un lecteur de carte donc il va falloir trouver une carte ! pour accéder à la porte Ok mec !
Voisin : Oh ! Squeezie : OUOOOO ! j'chui morts ! Oh IL Y A UN ETAGE !
OH IL Y A UNE GRILLE ! AAAAAH ! AAh  ca me stresse ! *pleure* Je deteste
Oh j'ai envie de chialer c'est pire que resident evil
bref il y avait un étage avec une grille sa m’intéresse ça là haut est-ce qu'on peut pas y aller ?
Là il y a ces escaliers ok donc c'est la qu'faut que j'aille
je pense qu'il y a moyen faire un saut un truc non ?
tsé faire un saut genre ah j'suis sure qu'y a moyen
Ah Putain !
Si on monte là haut il y a quoi si non ? Il y a un cadenas OH MERDE ! Oh ch'uis baisé Oh ! putin il m'a niqué
Ok donc dans les marches il y a ça et en haut il y a une porte avec un cadenas ok
C'est forcément par là ! C'est forcément par là
Tsé  le mec il a vue que 1% d'la maison mais *rires* C'EST FORCEMENT PAR LA !
Avec son vieux mannequin au milieu du couloir mec
mais qu fait ça PUTIN !
Voisin : Oh ! Squeezie :OOOOOAA *cri étouffé*
C'est bon j'ai redémarrer mon cœur
Il est déchainé c'est abusé putin !
Oh ! on va péter une fenêtre avec une chaussures
Personne pourra m’arrêter
Ok !
Wo wo wo wo Va's'y on va tenter par là ! LA D'SU ! LA D'SU ! Oh ! oui !
OH ! OUI !
Donc en fait fallait s'appuyer la dessus quoi ch'uis allé au culot sa à maché *bisous <3*Vive le culot !
Il y a une poignet pour ouvrir la grille mais la pire idée de la planète  on va jamais faire ça
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on a derrière cette porte du  coup on va forcément trouver des choses
en tout cas il pourra pas arriver de là si il vient de là mec c'est..c'est un ouf !
J'ai peur ça m'énerve ce putin d'violon là mon gars euh j'déteste ça
musique au violon (malaise)
c'est ça que je m'imagine quand j'entend ce bruit
Là on a quoi ? c'est fermé ok ! Et là on a quoi ? Il y a un cadenas !? Avec avec.. Un cadenas en or !? Faudrait une clé en or du coup
Ben mec sa veut dire que c'est forcément par là..Ben qu'est-ce que tu veut foutre ici ?
Faut sauter à gauche ? Il y a une porte la peut-être qu'on la vois pas ? Attend on va tenter
Oh merde en plus j'ai perdue la "light"(lampe torche)
Oh merde
C'était par là. Oh bâtard il est là ! On va faire très vite
OUWAAAAAA !
Oh Non ! j'suis juste tombé sur la tête
J'ai fait le fakir avec mon voisin voila c'est une manière de faire connaissance finalement
J'pense qu'on est sur la bonne piste mais voila il y a UN truc qu'on a oublié de faire si je puis me permettre Si vous me permettez de parler comme ça
En faite là haut regardé il y a un petit "switch"(interrupteur) à activer et normalement sa ouvrira ce truc là et normalement il y aura la clé pour ouvrir le cadenas en or
le truc c'est qu c'est super chaud à faire et on est jamais à l’abri que le mec se pointe genre heu..à tout moment quoi !
On va prendre deux cartons
et la table
Oui !!
Voisin : Oh ! Squeezie : Oh il arrive ! il arrive ! il arrive ! hen ! j'ai préféré partir oh la glue qui va me niquer nan c'est bon
Oh putin c'pas grave on à ouvert le truc normalement je vais pouvoir accéder à la clé
Je vais     pouvoir accéder a la clé
Je sais qu'a droit normalement je peut trouver une sorte d'aimant qui attire heu...les clé ! Et ça m'aiderait beaucoup
Vers ici il y a un putin d'objet normalement
vers là
vers cet endroit
Bien sur je le trouve pas
Oui !!!! OU OU OU ! Oh yes !
m'en bat les steaks que tu me cour après mon gars j'vais attirer la clé avec l'aimant et tu va êtres dégouttééééé !
OUIIIII !
Maintenant on monte on fait comme on a fait t'a l'heure
OK!
Ici j'ouvre la grille car ce sera plus simple de revenir car on vas se foirer en moins d'une seconde
Ok c'est partit on tente !
C'est Mais putin ce saut il est dur
La physique elle est chhhhTAA !!
Ah ! PUTIN !
Mais attendez ch'uis con on peut ouvrir le cadenas d'or faut pas faire le saut pour y aller
Ah ben c'est mort vla...NIKE TA MERE !! Pardon
je disait donc la chambre avec le putin de cadenas d'or j’avais oublier mais elle est là en faite
Voila !
Donc ici on à deux portes on a celle là...ouai une baignoire
avec rien dedans avec rien de cacher
dans les tiroirs il y a quoi il y a bien évidemment...absolument rien !
Et dans cette deuxieme porte il y a
Des tableaux des tableaux des tableaux et un grand espace et attend j'vais juste poser ça là
Oh ! il y a une porte au sol oh ! c'est un piège mais oui ! mais oui ça mène en bas ! ok c'est totalement un piege
Mais attend c'est nul mec c'est endroit est nul
Je suis v'nus là...pour RIEN !
La porte doré la on s'en bat les couilles elle ne sert à RIEN ! on s'est battut pour avoir cette clé pour RIEN !
Par contre j'veut réussir ce job mais c'est que la physique du jeu elle est NUL A CHIER !!
Et du coup et du coup j'arrive vraiment pas à faire ce saut quoi c'est une p'tite épreuve de "skill"(talent)
et on connait mon skill
Ok
*expiration*
OUWAA!
j'ai comprit j'croit qu'en faite faut vraiment sauter...il a mit des lasers !? il a mit une camera ! maintenant comme ça ! entre deux saut
P'tin mec faut carrément qu'il est un poste chez bricorama quoi c'est abusé
Allez on va y arriver !
Nan !
Non il est là ! AAAAH !
Mais PUTIN !
ch'uis en train de péter un câble là !
J'arrive pas à faire ce putin d'saut !
La physique est dégueulasse c'est impossible voila !
Fallait qu'ça sorte putin j'me sent mieux je m'sent exister (WTF !?)
Là ! Là ! regarder comment il fait ça en une seconde
le mec vi..step 17 d'jas il à fait 16 étapes nous on en a fait deux mais bon "osef"(rien à foutre) *rires*
Il court et il saute vraiment au dernier moment sa mère mais genre c'est une manipe de ouf !!
NANN !
L'autre qui campe regardez le ! Va t'acheter une putin d'vie
en plus il est buggé là où on doit aller
b'attend j'vait débloquer il galère là !
hallo ? bè débloque toi aussi là ! ben oui débloque toi
ben voila après ce jeu c'est un jeu de grande qualité on est d’accord
Il est vraiment buggé dans la fenêtre bè du coup j'peut passer là en faite
Est-ce que la chance nous sourit ? parceque là on est en train d'avoir de la chance
Bè non mais c'est incroyable !
Si je vait là il vient pas
Mais nan ! Mais la chance qu'on a mais oui ! Mais oui !
Alors...attention...*expiration*
*cri*
*expiration*
Tss !
Cette fois c'est la bonne je le sent
(musique épique)
OOOOOOH !!!!
Oh mec !
Oh mais vous vous rendez pas compte si il y avait pas eu le bug du gars sans déconnez
Donc là normalement j'vous retire cette merde ! Qu'est ce qu'il y a BIM ! c'est incroyable il y a vraiment une clé on la chope
et vous saver la clé de quoi c'est ?
Est-ce que vout saver c'est la clé de quoi ?...Moi oui !
On va y aller de ce pas pendant que l'autre pendant que l'autre est buggé comme un bon gros con !
Là il y a cette porte j'ai postillonner
ça dégage
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à découvrir ce qui se cache derrière cette porte
Est-ce que vous est prêt à découvrir pourquoi depuis deux heure on galère
*expiration*
C'est tout ? C'est TOUT !
attend là il y a un truc reliez à ça ch'ais pas quoi c'est quoi ce délire là ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si j'active ça ?
Sa monte et sa permet d’accéder à cette porte est ben on va LE FAIRE !!
Ah ! il y a une trappe là ! Elle m’amène où cette trape ? je vais aller regarder maintenant qu'on à fait le truc chiant de la vidéo on peut bien voir !
Ch'ui tomber mon gars c'est quoi cette trappe...Ah il y a un "shoot gun" ! (fusil)
That fucking amazing (C'est putin de génial)
on va pouvoir se venger ?
on va pouvoir baiser le gars qui est la cause de tout no mots
et la on à le truc en or d'accord je vois où on est !
Je vais remontez j'ai compris ce qu'il faut faire sa va encore être une manip chiante
Oh ! mon dieu
j'avais pas vue devant la grille du fusil à pompe la carte pour accéder au truc en bas
Qu'il y a t'il derrière cette porte ? Le peuple de France se le demande !
Attention on va découvrir son secret ! Attention sa va aller hyper vite !
Attention attention attention !
*Il parle très vite j'arrive pas à traduire*
C'est vert on ouvre la porte et...
Et il y a des truc en bois qui bloque *Rires* C'est pas grave je sais !
C'est pas grave "don't panic never panic"(ne panique pas ne panique jamais)
La camera est revenue c'est une excellente nouvelle !
On va dans la porte au cadenas doré
On passe par la fenêtre on atterris ici !
On chope l'échelle même si on fait 1 mètres 20 !
Voila tout est faisable même en fessant 1 mètre 20
Croiez en vos rêves
On atteint cet endroit ! On accèdes...à ça
On monte sur la table basse on saute dans le fenêtres
On a ici un pied de biche !
On passe par là vas'y on tombe on s'en bat les couilles t'es invincible
J'ai eu peur qui meurt mais c'est bon !
Et là mec...Oooo !
Qu'est ce qu...J'en ai rien à foutre que tu chiale
Faut qu j'aille le voir faut que je le console ?
J'ai gravie des fenêtres
J'ai tenter un saut avec une physique buggé plus de 600 fois !
Tout ça pour voir un mec chialer
J’arrête youtube !
Mais non mais Luca ne vois tu donc pas ?
Ça montre que malgré ses airs de méchant cet homme souffre
Tu ne connais pas son passé tu ne peut pas le critiqu...
FERME........TA GUEULEEEEEE !!
Aimez la vidéo et la je vous fait un braquage de "j'aime"
Ta pas aimer ? J'men bat les couil *rires*
Ca fait DEUX heures que je joue !
Ça fait deux heures que je joue
Oh putin les gens ça ma rendu fou !
Je suis content j'avais ma petite fierté de finir le jeu
C'était galère ! Imaginer si il avait pas buggé ! Si il était pas coincer dans un mur
Aller à bientôt merci d'avoir regardé t'chao tout l'monde "peace" ! (au revoir)
Musique drôle, lâche un like, abonne toi à la chaine de Squeezie et partage ;)